Brake position — or brake grip.
I have to correct myself there. Brake grip.
The brake can be held in various ways.
Up to now, and that's also fine, you can stick with that —
up to now you've kept the brake at the loop in the hand.
OK, and have flown turns from that grip.
That's completely fine.
Now it's like this, the brake has 10-12 cm of slack, sometimes also 15 cm,
and we need this slack for accelerated flight.
As soon as we accelerate, we tilt the canopy forward and down,
and the trailing edge at the back is a bit higher.
And when we fly straight, and you look up,
then our brake is bulging backward like this.
Makes a real arc, and that has to be the case, right?
Because as soon as we have accelerated flight, the brake at the back becomes taut.
And we mustn't pull the brake for that reason, in accelerated flight.
Because if we additionally pull the brake,
in that moment it briefly generates more lift here,
and the wing could collapse frontally.
Collapse asymmetrically — you can't say exactly.
In any case, collapse risk is significantly increased,
and for that reason you no longer steer in accelerated flight.
So you can lightly steer along on the rear there.
Up to now you've kept the brake at the loop in the hand like this.
And that's actually a problem, especially in thermal flying,
that you have to work with the brakes somewhere down there pretty deep.
With strong thermals you sometimes also have to brake more strongly.
That means the working area over a longer period is very, very strenuous.
And that's why many pilots go and shorten,
so to speak, this brake travel by holding the brake differently.
We have the so-called French grip.
The French often go there — not all, but many go through the brake loop
and now hold this line, brake line,
they hold this brake line between index finger and thumb.
Through this you have a very good feel.
You've also shortened the brake a bit.
Not all the way down there any more, but maybe now a bit up here.
So already somewhat more comfortable, more feel.
But the big disadvantage with it is, and that's why don't use it with me under any circumstances,
with thick gloves we probably won't get out of the brake loop any more.
There have already been fatal incidents — admittedly not fully proven,
but many pilots have confirmed that the pilot was using this technique.
And they saw that he couldn't
deploy the reserve parachute.
So it really could be due to the fact that you can't get out of the brake loop any more.
That means if you really want to do that, you can really do that
by simply leaving the thumb outside.
And that way you get out of this grip even faster.
The Hungarians, the Hungarian grip — the Hungarians then said,
wait, that's too risky for us.
But we still want to keep the brake line between index finger and thumb.
And that's why the Hungarians said,
or the Hungarians went to this and just held the brake like this.
That way you can of course let go at any time and grab the reserve parachute.
But the danger is also greater that you might really lose the line by accident.
And then you need a moment until you've grabbed it again.
From that point of view it's not necessarily a variant for me.
I don't personally like it.
We go and shorten the brake really extremely.
So we take this 10 to 12 cm of slack, we take that out,
by keeping the brake quite normally at the loop in the hand
and making a so-called wrap outward.
Do you see that? So I turn it outward
and now I lead this brake line here past the heel of the hand
and can hold it loosely between index finger and thumb in the hand.
I have a very good feel for the wing
and now have a very short steering travel.
That means I now only work here
and through that it's much less strenuous.
I just have a shorter travel, feel the wing better,
less strenuous and the advantage,
I can take the wrap back out at any time.
Or, if I need one more,
I take one more in.
Stall for example, A-rated wing.
There I have to wrap twice.
So a very big advantage
and for certain manoeuvres also a very good option.